and government people are under oath
saying yes I mean yes there our crafts
yes we have biological entities like
aliens also who were piloting those
crafts and all of that exists and that
is happening right now under oath Tom
dong tweeted I saw his his tweet I was I
was right aliens exist so is it a
coincidence though that this is the same
that the the Biden jury or trial starts
like are they trying to cover up what's
going on with like the the Biden could
conveniently timed for that like oh
let's do it that day but still this has
been in the works for a long time but
it's always like when something else is
in the news they bring up UFOs haven't
you notic that but nobody cares about
UFOs so it's not effective to Tom long I
care about UFOs I mean it's one of the
biggest questions you can have okay so
are there biological
entities Among Us like uh the we see as
humans but they're not humans that I
have not heard I mean I've seen
conspiracies on that that's of course
there's conspiracies on that but but
from I've only seen a little bit of this
footage of the trials but it was just
they're called bi
biologics that that's what they're
calling non-human biologics so they're
not saying humanoid or human looking
things they're saying nothing about
walking Among Us or anything like that
they're just saying from what I saw
crafts have been recovered and there
were pilots of some of those crafts
which have also been recovered I didn't
hear anything about they been identified
as nonhuman nonhuman yes they identify
as non human they identify as
nonh are are they mad at us that I don't
know but there was one question like has
there been any violence like from them
like towards the people around and the
guys said like yeah there's been some
like some of the stuff me and my wife
saw like what did he say yeah he said I
saw some disturbing things that's what
he said like in a question referring to
like have they like hurt anybody in this
process um and uh there were people who
were murdered in a cover up attempt I
didn't see anything about that y like
what you talking about Google that
murdered by who you're talking about
Obama's Chef that just died no no no no
no I I
saw um I saw there a headline that um
the people were murdered in UFO
coverups where
when wh anyone been murdered Jesus well
okay so this is the guy who's on trial
the congressman as UFO whistleblower if
anyone has been murdered to maintain
alleged coverup and what did he say Tim
brusett asked the government
whistleblower whether he believes
anyone's been murdered blah blah blah
very very bottom right there do you have
any personal knowledge of people who
have been harmed or injured in efforts
to cover up and conceal these these
extraterrestrials yes replied
personally I mean has anyone been
murdered he hesitated for a moment he
hesitated for a moment before saying I
have to be careful asking that question
he said citing a current investigation
whether or not subject blah blah blah I
directed I directed people with that
knowledge to the appropriate authorities
so so yes sort of alluding to so he said
there's been murders so it's this one
guy who's like a whistleblower but
there's many of them out there he's
probably just the first guy that's on
trial but I feel like there's been other
people in front of Congress talking
about it Dr David Greer he's big Bob
Lazar Bob Lazar but I don't think Bob
lazar's ever spoken in front of Congress
he should has he no I've just seen him
on like Rogan and stuff okay so there's
UFOs what does that like mean how does
that affect my daily
life I don't know so you don't care at
all about aliens
tell me why UFOs big
whoop like tell tell me how that changes
anything I mean we're not alone in the
universe there's aliens that have landed
on planet Earth and they're here are
they mad at us I don't know I think they
I don't know but this may affect your
life I mean they said they started
showing up when we started like
inventing nuclear bombs but you're
you're sort of conflating like
conspiracy theories and this like this
guy hasn't said that you're just saying
that's a general
assume did you watch Oppenheimer no not
yet did you yeah how was you like it uh
when I whenever I watch a movie that's
based on a true story like I immediately
turn around and then watch the actual
documentary like or whatever and in the
case of Oppenheimer like sure when
they're like counting down like they're
blowing up the test bomb like that's
super intense it's like really eerie
when they have like the Box up bombs
that are being sent to go
bomb Japan that that's super crazy um
but overall I kind of felt like it was
just uh I I wasn't really getting it I
was like man I can't wait to get home
and watch like a more like easy to
digest true story about it h did you see
Barbie I did not see Barbie but Barbie
blew it out of the water huh yeah bar
Barbie killed it yeah yeah what what
would what score would you give
Oppenheimer out of 1 to
100 I didn't think it was that great man
I I like it just never grabbed you you
never really gave a [__] during it like
it felt like the full three hours it
didn't feel like a full three hours but
I was just like ah with the artisticness
you know like just tell me the story I
mean how was San
Murphy silly was he a silly boy I mean
he he
was It was kind of cool that he spoke
with an American accent but he did it
kind of weird I I don't know I I want to
love selan Murphy I want to love like
Robert Dy Jr like all all of it and I'm
not mad at it I'm not saying it was bad
so you wouldn't recommend didn't think
it was that great did you see Barbie no
no no not yet not yet yeah I'm probably
going to go see it I mean another news I
went to the UCLA Medical uh examiner
today yeah you got a finger up your butt
I got a finger up my butt and for the
pro check no it was
horrible
have you ever had it I mean I's
like two knuckle deep and you're just
like which
knuckle probably the point I I don't
know he probably does two fingers like I
didn't like it he put in one finger and
you said uno
uno no you're just
like and then you see white but you guys
you see white I mean yeah dude it's like
dude if you're if you're having foreplay
it's like you're you're you're riming
the but hole you're working your way in
you don't just go into the [__] she
just goes right in so you want him to
tickle it a little bit
first yeah I mean doctors would just do
a little bit of foreplay it wouldn't
hurt as much was he lubed up yeah I mean
bro what kind of your butth holes
dilated the 10 like a [__] pregnant
lady every I mean dude you saw what we
put up there I mean come on if but took
Time Imagine just going straight in it's
going to be like so he just goes yeah
this is this is Scott like tryina like
oh so was so
bad yeah I'm not gay or no all white but
you it's not a pleasurable experience I
saw white everything went white I lost
earing ear started ringing you've had a
prostate you've had a prostate
examination and it wasn't a big deal I
blocked out can anybody in the comments
like like talk about that it was painful
or not but anyway so so after they did
the test they uh I had have high
cholesterol and I was like talking to
about losing weight you already have
results and it was today dude it was
like the most [__] while his fingers
in there he's like oh yeah high
cholesterol hold on yeah oh yeah it's
high do you like shopping on Amazon I do
and good news is sto's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your but
plus sto's butthole destroyer and sto's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude